l'instant il n'y a pas énormément nom
dont on le ressent il ya une mise en
place il ya beaucoup de restaurateurs
acquis à nous avons parlé mais qui ne
voulaient pas s'épancher sur le sujet en
tout cas assez le sésame à présenter à
l'entrée à des cafés et des restaurants
pour as attablés en terrasse ou tout
simplement pour dîner ou déjeuner on a
pu parler à jules restaurateurs et
gérants du restaurant italienne
trattoria qui appréhendent un petit peu
est la procédure avec les clients je
propose de l'écouter
déjà on va commencer par télécharger
l'application tout sauf si kobe tu
vérifies sur la table est posté
quelqu'un donc ça fait du personnel en
plus à l'accueil
enfin à l'entrée il va y avoir une
personne qui sera en charge en
l'occurrence moi aujourd'hui
donc oui pour pour vraiment contrôler
tout le monde puisque on peut pas
rentrer sans pass sanitaire voit une
clientèle jeune en plus donc sûrement
pas forcément vacciner et puis après
pour limiter la terrasse dans les jours
à venir on va sûrement m'aider
serre-file également pour pas que les
gens puissent s'installer sans notre
sans notre accord et donc sans contrôle
et puis et puis nous verrons bien
comment on arrivera à gérer le flux si
vous justement comment est-ce que vous
est-ce que vous appréhendez se passe
sanitaire qu'est ce qu'est ce que vous
en pensez
alors appréhendé c'est un bien grand mot
parce qu'on s'y prend on s'y prépare et
on le savait ça fait un moment qu'on en
parle maintenant
oui on a peur sur le chiffre d'affaires
ce qu'on l'a vue sur tout ce qui est
cinéma et santos a vachement baisser le
chiffre d'affaires plus de 70% pour les
cinémas j'espère que c'est pas ce qui va
se passer pour nous encore une fois on a
une clientèle jeune c'est pas la
population qui est la plus vaccinée donc
oui on on peut dire qu'on appréhende
mais on est préparé comment est ce que
vous vous ferez si un client par exemple
n'a pas son passé à lithaire on ne veut
pas montrer patte blanche si je puis
dire bah écoutez on lui refuserait
l'accès au restaurant
après c'est pas forcément notre métier
de base maintenant ça fait deux ans
qu'on s'y plient avec les masques ça
nous est encore arrivé il ya deux jours
on a eu un accrochage avec un client bon
malheureusement s'il fait un voilà ça
fait partie du job dont je préfère ça
que d'être fermé clairement je préfère
perdre du chiffre d'affaires que d'être
fermée après elle aux restaurateurs on a
également pu parler à quelques clients
qui étaient attablés à une terrasse à
deux cafés ils trouvent en général que
c'est plutôt une bonne chose
écoutez là bas je pense que c'est une
bonne idée ça peut éviter que les gens
se contaminent et vaudrait mieux que
tout le monde soit vaccinée pour qu'on
évite que le coc vite se propage
bon alors le passé ni terre
moi je suis pour ou contre ce à la
limite je me pose pas vraiment la
question mais disons que je pense que
pour les restaurateurs effectivement
c'est une bonne chose ça leur permet de
rester ouvert après est-ce que c'est un
bon choix ça je peux pas vraiment
répondre mais je pense que pour les
restaurateurs c'est une bonne chose
à sa toute première fois après de toute
manière on est un peu obligé de le faire
pour qu'on puisse sortir de la crise
donc on va faire le nécessaire pour que
tout le monde avance dans le même sens
et
et qu'on puisse enfin sortir ces
différentes va quoi on est obligé entre
guillemets 1 si on veut avancer faut
aussi de la loi que vous l'avez entendu
beaucoup d'appréhension et d'inquiétudes
de la part des restaurateurs ses clients
vous les avez entendus trouve que c'est
plutôt une bonne chose d'autre nous
avait dit que ça pouvait être un
inconvénient
en tout cas pour les restaurateurs qui
ne vérifient pas c'est pas sanitaires et
bien il risque une amende de 1500 euros